All right,
so I'm going to click record and then we're just going to take a couple of
seconds of silence and then we'll jump right into it.
Start shaking you.
Plus
I'm a cybernetic organism.
Thank you for supporting the sponsors of this show.
99 designs,
which is your one stop shop for all things graphic design related,
go to 99 designs.com forward slash Tim to see the projects that I've put up,
including the mockups and drafts of the book cover for the four hour body.
As always,
you can subscribe to this podcast on iTunes and you can find all of the links
and resources from this episode as well as every other episode by going to four
hour workweek.com forward slash podcast spell it all out or you can go to four
hour workweek.com and just click on podcast feedback.
If you have feedback,
I would love your thoughts,
anything at all who you'd like to see on this show,
ping me on Twitter at t Ferris.
That's twitter.com forward slash t f,
e R R,
I s s or on facebook@facebook.com forward slash Tim Ferriss with two r's and two
s's.
Hello
girls,
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
I deconstruct world class performers,
whether they be billionaire,
hedge fund managers,
early stage investors like Peter Teal or celebrities,
Arnold Schwarzenegger,
musicians,
chess prodigies and so on.
They have commonalities and they do have tools and tricks and routines that you
can use.
This episode I am interviewing Amanda Palmer who is a musician but also a social
media virtuoso and innovator as a musician from the standpoint of both music and
business models.
Some of you I'm sure have seen her hit Ted presentation,
the art of asking,
which has been viewed more than 6 million times,
but her story goes much,
much deeper and we will plumb the depths.
We will talk about of course,
perhaps,
uh,
the Dresden dolls and where she first rose to prominence is one half of that
acclaimed pump cabaret duo.
Then the journey from solo album to leaving her record label all together and
experimenting with things like Kickstarter.
She made international news in 2012 when she raised nearly 1.2 million
preselling.
Her new album theater is evil,
which went on to debut in the billboard top 10.
It's one hell of a story.
And she's also known as the Social Media Queen of rock and roll for her constant
and disarmingly intimate.
And I say disarmingly intimate,
such as standing naked in front of a room full of fans who sign your body with
various markers.
I'm not kidding.
Uh,
engagement with fans via her blog,
tumbler,
Twitter,
where she has more than a million followers and she has really opened a lot of
eyes to say a direct to fan or pay what you want,
business models for building and running her business.
So we get into all of this,
uh,
and we of course dip our toe in the different tactics and stories from the art
of asking,
uh,
how she manages relationships and much more.
So let me stop this preamble and allow you to enjoy a very fun conversation.
I enjoyed immensely with Amanda Palmer.
Cassie's cass,
cass,
you say,
give this to God,
even in tow to sing that.
Amanda
fucking Paul,
welcome to the show.
Thank you Tim fucking Ferris.
Howard.
Fuck you.
I am great.
And the only reason I ask or rather introduce things that way is because I've
been dying to ask you.
You have Amanda fucking Palmer listed as your alias or also known as everywhere.
I've been able to really try to do homework including Wikipedia.
How did you end up with fucking is an alternate middle name?
Well,
as you know,
Wikipedia is not authored by the,
uh,
it's not offered by the artists.
Right.
Amanda fucking Palmer is a,
is a joke nickname that Ben folds gave me while I was working on my first solo
album.
And the,
the funny thing about the name is,
um,
it was,
it was actually aimed at me as an insult.
It was sort of,
it was one of those take back the night moments.
Um,
you know,
like,
uh,
well,
like all the words that you're not allowed to say.
Yeah,
you can,
you can say anything on this podcast doing.
But I mean it was one of those things where Ben Ben had someone who was a,
uh,
a friend of occur,
an enemy who referred to me every time she referred to me,
she referred to me as Amanda fucking Palmer.
And so Ben as a joke,
because we were working on a record in Nashville together for like a month as a
joke started calling me AFP.
It just became the cause you and you also like,
you lose your mind in the studio and everything devolves into toilet humor
instantly.
Um,
that just became the running studio joke and then,
you know,
that was Ben's pet name for me.
And I thought it was funny enough that I started using it myself and then it
just sort of turned into a thing.
I don't even know how it turned into a thing,
but I think that's a good nickname isn't really deliberately.
It'd kind of like,
it lands on you and then it sticks like glue.
Oh,
so you,
you,
you disarmed the insult by adopting it completely,
which kind of is my life philosophy.
I love that.
Take on the pain and wear it as a shirt.
Oh,
I love this.
And I'll just,
I'll treat a really quick anecdote,
which is,
uh,
I was really bummed out at some point a few years ago when a new book came out
and,
uh,
got panned by this guy in the New York Times and I don't particularly like,
and I teach,
but I,
what I decided to do as retribution steel part of his,
that's exactly what I took.
I took part of it,
which was intended to be this over the top insult,
but out of context,
it sounds amazing.
It was like Tim Ferriss walks on air,
air and land or something at like.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
And I put it on the,
I put it on the inside flap of the four hour chef as a reward.
I have a,
I have an indie rock friend who got panned and like,
you know,
I don't know if it was the new year,
it was the indie rock equivalent of the New York Times,
which means it was,
you know,
it was pitchfork or something.
And they wrote this scathing,
you know,
no stars review of his new album's saying,
so and so thinks he is like the second coming of Christ and the most amazing
musical genius to ever walk the face of the planet.
And he just removed the kidney,
the beginning of that and stole the rest of the quote and a foster dad on his
press kit.
And I was like,
you are awesome.
Yeah.
The uh,
the,
the movie poster.
Dot,
dot,
dot.
Matt Amazing.
What magic can be worked doing things that way.
I have a confession and that is your book,
the art of asking.
I,
uh,
I got halfway through it.
And the reason I haven't read the second half is because I was so inspired by
the book that I put it down to start asking people around me for all of the help
that I've been too ashamed or embarrassed to ask for an Ezra assault.
I have fixed my no more time to read.
I have no more time to read,
so busy asking.
And I,
uh,
ended up fixing my health after a severe bout with Lyme disease lashed last year
and have just had these multiple quantum leaps forward.
So I wanted to thank you for putting the book out there,
first of all.
Oh,
that's wonderful.
I'm so happy to hear that.
Actually.
I'd rather hear that than hear they need that you've finished my book and loved
it,
but it didn't change anything in your life.
It makes me really happy.
Oh,
I was,
I was so just completely smitten with the book.
And the subtitle I think is really important.
Uh,
so correct me if I get this wrong,
but I've,
I believe it's how I learned to stop worrying and let people help.
And I wanted to ask you,
and of course we're going to come back to some of your background and everything
else,
but why did you book is a hard thing.
I mean a lot of things in life are hard,
but books are,
are uh,
are a challenge.
Why did you decide to put this book together and put it out there?
I don't think I would've put this book together if I hadn't been offered a
totally.
Um,
we will make this easy for you book deal because I've been,
I'm one of those people who's always got,
you know,
19 projects on the back burner and one of them was someday I should write a
book,
I'll write a book someday when I have time.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Like you know,
somebody who tours 250 days a year and has,
you know,
millions of unrecorded songs and you know,
all sorts of Bizarro side projects.
You know,
a book always seemed like a great thing in theory and in practice,
just a huge pain in the ass and not something that I ever really imagined
fitting into my life as a,
as a runner around her.
Um,
cause I know enough about book writing to know that it's not something I could
like tap out on the fly on flights from one place to the other.
I was really going to have to put press pause on my life as I knew it.
And after I,
um,
started working on my ted talk,
you know,
I had a had,
I'd have the,
the vague idea of writing a book sort of the,
the first time I really thought about it other than the basic narcissistic,
oh,
write my memoirs someday,
which I think every,
every artist who lives in kind of an off kilter,
bizarre life with interesting stories.
Probably has the thought someday to just write the stories down.
But the first time I really thought about writing a book was,
was actually after my experience street performing because street performing in
my particular experiences treat performing was,
it was so unique.
And I didn't know of anybody out there who had written about what it was like to
be a living statue.
And,
and then later in my life with crowdfunding and the Internet and really seeing
the connections,
the,
the strange but philosophical connections between living statue work and
stripping and starting a band and trusting fans and asking for money.
And I was like,
all of these things are really related.
They're all kind of part of one philosophy and one story and that would make a
great book.
And it's,
uh,
and it's,
and it's unlike anything else I know.
I mean,
it's not really a book about music.
It's not really a book about being a street performer.
It's kind of a book about an approach to life that is about abundance and trust
instead of about scarcity and fear,
you know,
in the frame of art and performance art.
But also like,
as I found,
as I kept carving out the book,
it's,
you know,
it was also about relationships and um,
a risk and,
you know,
kind of the big themes.
And once I did the Ted talk,
you know,
while I was working on the Ted talk,
I worked together with my really good friend Jamie and Swiss who's this
fantastic magician and SAS and you know,
he sort of fell into my lap as my ted coach cause I called him one night and I
knew that he had given talks at conferences.
So he was one of the people in my life that I could tap.
As you know,
you understand Ted,
you understand conferences.
I can't ask most of my friends about this.
Um,
you know what makes a good talk?
Can I read you what I've written?
And I had what I thought was going to be a 20 minute phone call turned into a
three hour phone call with Jamie giving me all sorts of advice and all sorts of
opinions and all sorts of,
you know,
calling me on my bullshit.
And by the end of that three hours,
I was like,
Jamie,
you're going to have,
you're going to be my wing man on this Ted talk.
If you help me do this,
I will love you forever.
And he was like,
I'm here for you.
I will help you with this ted talk.
So I would say he's sort of like the hidden hero man behind the curtain of my
ted talk because he was the guy on the phone with me every other day for an hour
while I read him draft after draft after draft of my ted talk.
And there's a reason my ted talk wound up so good.
I didn't just knock it out and read it.
I worked slaved on that fucker for to really like it was,
it was like constructing a perfect little monologue with no fat and just the
right cadence.
And I,
I really,
really,
I really worked hard on it.
But one of the things that happened as I added little anecdotes and added
stories and we cut them and we refined and honed and decided that this was a
little too off topic,
is we came up with the phrase,
you know,
it'll go in the book.
You don't have to put it in the talk and then you only have 12 minutes that'll
go in your book someday.
And so that was when the imaginary book took shape,
which is,
you know,
for this 12 minute ted talk,
I was trying to condense my entire life philosophy,
you know,
into into a teeny amount of time that there were so many other stories that were
relevant.
And I comforted myself with the idea that if the Ted talk resonated,
I would someday expanded all into a talk.
And then I didn't have to worry about that at all because the minute that Ted
talk went online and went viral,
my phone rang off the hook with,
with book deals and I,
and I just decided I would take one and I would do an a and then I would just
like go down the rabbit hole and figure out how to write a book.
The Ted talk is fantastic.
And for people listening,
I'll put the Ted talk in the show notes so you guys can check that out as well.
It's a great introduction to the,
the then expanded narrative and collection of stories and lessons.
That is the book of course.
Uh,
and I'm sure when you wrote the book you're like,
well,
it doesn't all have to go in the book.
This will be the online extras.
But the,
the mention of Ted and the,
uh,
the Amanda Whisper,
your friend who is helping you with the presentation,
I called him Ted Doula and then the book exactly the Ted Doula.
I'd be very interested to hear what some of the,
the best feedback or,
or changes were that he gave to you for the,
for the Ted talk itself.
Well,
you know,
a lot of it was not unlike writing a book.
And since you've written,
I'm sure you,
you know,
this quandary,
which is you get so interested in your topic that you keep wanting to expand and
expound and,
and,
and the true beauty of making a good ted talk or a good book is that you edit
down and you,
and you distill.
And so the key with the Ted talk was,
you know,
I kept wanting to add like,
oh my God,
and then there's this and how can I not talk about this?
And you know,
there was this amazing thing that happened and are,
you know,
and our,
and our goal was to just literally using an economy of language.
You know,
I would write a sentence and write an anecdote and speak it.
I would be on Skype with Jamie and it would take me a minute and a half to tell
this story about couch surfing,
you know,
with this,
this girl and her family down in Florida.
And then the goal was how do we take this story that took a minute and a half to
tell and I thought I had got it as far down economically as possible and then
take that minute and a half story and condense it into 20 seconds.
What literally what words,
what single words could we use to convey that whole sentence and it,
and it was like songwriting or poetry where instead of saying and expounding and
going off on Tangents,
you just pick that one perfect sentence that sums up everything you've felt.
And in that sense there was a,
there was a real artistry behind it.
And I've found watching other Ted and looking at other ted talks,
they have that in common,
which was an economy of emotion and of expression.
You know,
they didn't need to explain this and that.
And the other thing they with a single anecdote or a single detail,
they emotionally take you right there and they don't need to say anymore and
they can get onto the next thing.
Yeah.
It brings to mind a couple of things.
The first was an exercise that a writing professor of mine back in college named
John,
uh,
fee used to have us do,
which would be to take something like the,
get a Gettysburg address and have to pull out five lines or six lines and a,
which was always so torturous.
But uh,
separately was told very early on,
I think it was related to,
to teaching as opposed to writing.
Although I think that the two are very similar when you're talking about
nonfiction and that was most teaching fails from too much information,
not too little.
And I think that,
sure Ted presentations are very similar.
I think you could say that about art.
Sure.
Yeah.
Like the best art is,
is about economy.
And,
and you know,
even if you're,
you know,
even if your art is,
durational performance art,
um,
even within that,
there can be an economy because the artist who's just trying to do everything,
you know,
wines up,
uh,
unable to express whatever it is that's of importance.
Durational performance art.
What would be an example of durational performance art?
Uh,
I mean,
Marina Abramovich sitting in a,
sitting in Moma for three months.
Got It.
That's a long duration.
That's
the ration.
That's durational performance art.
But if you look at a,
if you look at Marina Abramovich sitting in a Moma for three months there,
there was an economy about what she did.
You know,
she didn't wear a different costume every day and you know,
also try to do 90 other things at once.
It was her and a chair and another person.
And there was a real economy in that.
So,
you know,
I've,
I've definitely had a battle all my life with economy.
you know,
I'm an,
I'm a maximalist and I have driven collaborators and managers and boyfriends and
girlfriends.
And pretty much everybody in my wife crazy because I always want it.
I want to add more and I want to do more and Oh my God,
if we're going to do this,
we could do this on top of it and we could do this too with like let's add more
dancing girls and let's add more.
You know,
more of like more triangle,
like all the,
you know,
more cow bell,
all the things.
And you know,
as an,
as an artist and you,
you see this in the wisdom of older artists as they,
as they talk about their processes,
they pay like your life,
you know,
your life goes on and you pair down and you keep paring down to the point where
you realize that it wasn't the extra performance artists that made your show
good.
It was the ability to pair down to the detail,
the impactful detail.
And you know,
that's,
that's just true in art as in life for sure.
And how,
how have you become,
do you feel like you have become better at editing and distilling in your art?
And if so,
what has been the most helpful in getting you to that point?
Um,
that's a really good question because it also really depends on the form,
you know,
songwriting as a good example,
songwriting and um,
you know,
and even recording songs is a good example.
I used to think,
here's a really specific,
that a really good lesson
I used to think and one would think that if you were just recording a single
song,
you know,
but let's say it's a really aggressive piano song and it's just piano and
vocals,
you would think that layering and overdubbing more piano would make for a
stronger sound.
So instead of just having,
you know,
one single piano playing a baseline and a right hand and your vocal on top of
it,
you know,
you record the piano 10 times over.
And so you've basically got the entire end of the piano on the recording and you
crank everything up to 11.
And the fascinating thing about that is and,
and incredibly poetic as related to the rest of art and life is the strongest
loudest sound you can get from a piano is playing two notes,
you know,
a low C and a middle e and banging the shit out of those two notes is way more
impactful and striking and strong and aggressive than overdubbing 27 notes on
top of that.
And you know,
ACDC is kind of a perfect example.
You know,
those,
those guitar rifts and those single notes,
they burned themselves into your brain and they don't need a whole lot of extra.
It's the,
it's the,
it's the sheer,
you know,
epic simplicity of um,
of the,
of the minimal.
And you know,
I've found that this is true pretty much everywhere in life,
especially when it comes to,
I mean you were mentioning it with teaching.
It was,
it's something that I have been learning in my relationships from day one and
still struggle with to this day and found myself even doing in the last 48 hours
of my relationship with Neal,
which is learning how to say less.
And especially for someone like me who's a motor mouth and you know,
wants to be constantly communicating and engaged.
The ability to have a thought and not just blurted out and to have something
that you think is interesting that you want to share or to have an observation
or a criticism and not say it and,
and deliberate and consider is this actually useful?
Is this actually compassionate?
This is actually necessary to the conversation or does saying less actually
leave more space for more love.
And I have found the best,
the best advice from my mentor.
Um,
who else to talk about in the book does,
and funny enough,
it's pretty economical advice as well is,
is life advice to me when I'm going into a conflict or a difficult situation
with my parents or you know,
an argument with Neal,
his advice is say less.
That's it.
Just to say less.
It's such good advice.
Great advice or emails to,
we should just skip the next 60 minutes of the podcast.
Play two notes on a piano for the next 45 minutes.
Please stand by.
Uh,
I wanna I wanna I definitely wanna come back to,
uh,
the relationship,
your relationship briefly a little further down the road,
but I'd love to rewind the clock a little bit and talk about the,
uh,
eight foot bride.
Could you give people a little bit of context for those who don't know your
story?
Uh,
just a little bit of context on the eight foot bride.
And the question I'd like to then add on that is just what your main lessons
learned were from that experience that have translated to all of the other
endeavors and experiments that you've had.
Okay.
Well,
the basic background is,
um,
is that I was a living statue and most people know what that is because they've
seen it if they've traveled to any metropolis,
but you don't know what a living statue is.
It's a street performer.
Um,
usually monochromatically colored,
you know,
all white,
all silver,
all blue face painted gloves and sometimes living statues,
wear sunglasses and wigs.
And you know,
my least favorite living statues where wear masks,
I think that's cheating.
Um,
because there's a real beauty and watching somebody frozen face,
that's a real,
that's a,
um,
that's a real part of the talent.
But I basically graduated college.
Um,
I knew I wanted to be a,
or a musician.
I knew I was either going to go into music or theater,
but my main passion was song writing and I,
you know,
it's working my collection of shitty jobs.
Um,
my,
my main shitty job being,
um,
and it was a great,
Shitty job just in case my old boss is listening because I love him.
I worked in a,
in a fantastic little ice cream shop in,
in Harvard Square that was called Toscanini's and we scooped ice cream and made
coffee for the Denisons of Harvard Square and,
and Harvard.
And,
um,
I had seen street performers,
you know,
all my life.
And I had,
I had,
I remember mentally noting,
you know,
every time I saw living statue
who does that and you know,
who gives you permission to do that?
And I could do that.
You know,
anyone could clearly do that.
You just need to paint yourself and get on a box.
Um,
and so one day I just,
I just did it.
I painted myself white and put on a bridal gown and avail and some gloves.
And I stood on a box.
I was terrified.
Um,
and I,
and I put,
uh,
I put a hat at my feet,
um,
and I gave out flowers and you know,
that first time I got up and did that,
it was a real,
it was sort of one of those life breakthrough moments where I felt so
I felt so fraudulent.
I was like,
this isn't,
no one's giving me permission to do this.
No one's taught me how to do this.
I'm really faking this.
I mean,
I assume you just stand here.
No.
Are there rules for being a statue?
And I,
and I just did it.
And it was,
it was delightful.
And I really,
I,
I had this moment of incredible feeling,
incredible freedom.
Just,
you know,
taking that $17 I made that day and just going out and buying a sandwich and a
packet of cigarettes and going,
oh my God,
this money is just mine.
People just gave it to me.
I,
you know,
it was such a,
it was such a um,
uh,
you know,
like a Eureka moment after only having been,
been given money,
you know,
in the form of a paycheck from a boss to just have people giving you pulled hard
cast for performing and the street was a real,
really beautiful feeling.
Um,
and I never went back after that.
Although being a,
being a living statue and in Boston is a clearly seasonal occupation.
So,
you know,
I would sort of,
um,
I would go back to,
to,
you know,
to cafe work in the winters or I would,
I would travel and perform the eight foot bride in,
in warmer hospital will climbs.
Like I went down to key west and I went to La.
I tried my hand at Vegas,
I went to Australia when,
one winter.
But I would say I made about 95% of my living statue income right in the middle
of Harvard Square over the course of,
you know,
four or five years.
And it really,
you know,
it wasn't until I looked back,
um,
after,
you know,
after years of having transferred into the music and rocking and rolling tour in
performer career,
that I realized how much street-life and busking life has shaped my approach to
everything.
You know,
my,
my life philosophy was not an academic approach.
It was not a music business approach.
It was a busking approach,
which is you have to,
you have to be good at what you do.
And,
um,
and then you rely on the goodwill of others.
And that's the way busking works.
You know,
nobody buys a ticket.
You,
you do your thing and you have to captivate a crowd and,
and then you pass your hat.
What separates a good living statue from a great living?
Oh,
you know,
I think,
I think there's two answers to that question.
I have seen some shitty fucking living statues and I have seen some,
have seen some people with the,
who have put the absolute minimal amount of care and effort into their costumes
and makeup.
Um,
and it's always really depressing to me to see a bad living statue.
You know,
someone who's just like,
you know,
wearing a rain coat and a bad mask and isn't even really standing still,
and has barely interacting with,
um,
with the people who are giving the money.
And,
you know,
regardless,
everyone has always curious about a living statue.
Even a bad living statue.
And,
you know,
in children's curiosity is,
is unrelenting.
So they can't really tell the difference between an immaculate living statue who
spent $2,000 on a,
you know,
an a beautiful latex costume that looks completely realistic.
You know,
or,
or someone who's just,
you know,
wearing a shitty raincoat and a mask.
All they know is that there's something happening and it might be magic and they
put their dollar and something magical is going to happen.
Um,
but you know,
I've seen,
I have seen some really incredible living statues with just glorious costumes
and they,
you know,
they're,
they're just killing it in the aesthetics department,
but they don't love you.
And my favorite,
my favorite living statues are the ones who have some Patheos and,
and who actually connect with you.
Um,
and that was the approach I took to,
uh,
to the eight foot bride,
which is,
you know,
I as a,
as a performer,
hungry for love and connection.
I treated every single patron,
um,
as a,
as like a ten second love affair.
And I,
I just,
I enjoyed so deeply the act of looking into a stranger's eyes and thanking them
for giving me a quarter that,
um,
you know,
that it was a real part of the job,
but also means that,
you know,
I'm really disappointed if I go up to a living statue.
And they're like,
yeah,
you gave me a dollar now fuck off.
Sad,
cheap trick or something.
So what,
you mentioned eye contact and you have v you have very striking icontact and
certainly use that in your ted talk.
And I,
I've seen it in other photographs and videos.
What advice would you give?
I think that most people avoid excessive eye contact,
but what advice would you give to average Joe or Jane out there about
using icontact,
connect with people?
What are your thoughts on that?
Uh,
I have a lot of thoughts on that.
I mean,
I,
I think,
I think eye contact is very hard for a lot of us because it is,
it's so threatening and the more disconnected we are and the more time we spend
looking into our devices and barely looking at each other,
um,
the more threatening it is to,
to,
to keep and hold somebody's gaze.
But God,
is it powerful?
I mean,
looking somebody in the eye unthreatening Lee,
um,
on aggressively it is,
it is the,
I really feel like it is often the antidote for what is ailing us because we
feel so connected superficially in so many ways.
And perhaps we are through our Twitter feeds,
through our Facebook feeds,
through our many events,
through our doing this and that.
I'm running around.
But if we're able to do all that and we're not able to look at and see each
other,
it all,
it all can feel really superficial.
And I had some,
I had some really life changing experiences,
um,
in yoga retreats particularly.
And I read about one of them in the book,
one of the,
one of the first teacher training,
yoga retreats I went on.
I was,
it was probably 26,
27 and we did this exercise where,
um,
you know,
there's maybe 50 of us in the group total and,
and we did this exercise where we,
we got into groups of like 10 and we took turns just standing in a line facing
each other.
Um,
and it was basically an exercise in,
in presence and the,
and the goal was just to stand there and face another person,
maybe about a foot apart.
Ida,
I
just gazing into each other's eyes and not reacting,
not smiling,
not giggling,
not rolling our eyes,
not saying,
oh,
it doesn't this feel kind of uncomfortable and silly that just really just
holding the gaze.
And what was so incredible to me about that,
and this is after I had clocked my five years,
is,
uh,
you know,
living statue.
So I of course I'm just loving this,
I'm soaking this in.
This is like,
you know,
crack cocaine to meet basically like,
yeah,
I get to just look in someone's eyes for three minutes and then I get to look in
someone else's eyes.
And I just,
to me,
the,
the juicy intimacy of that was,
uh,
you know,
felt like a warm bath,
but for six or seven people in that group of 50,
they burst out sobbing.
They could not handle
actually what w and W and we did a lot of talking and kind of breaking down in a
postmortem of this experience afterwards.
And it wasn't even the,
they felt overwhelmed by having to look at someone else.
They felt overwhelmed by actually feeling seen by another person.
And the,
the emotion,
the emotional,
overwhelming,
uh,
experience of,
of feeling really just,
you know,
intimately seen by another,
having spent possible an entire lifetime,
not being seen by their parents,
not being seen by their peers,
not being seen by the people around them and maybe avoiding it,
you know,
for reasons of fear,
fear of intimacy,
fear of being found out,
fear of whatever it was.
And I remember looking at this and these weren't fucked up people,
these were,
you know,
these are your average,
a totally functional adults in their thirties with jobs and kids and the whole
nine.
And I remember thinking like,
this isn't just them.
I mean this is really all of us.
We,
we do not connect with each other at nearly the level
we could.
And though we live in close proximity and though we sit on the subway with each
other and though we,
you know,
though we have a wide variety of things connecting us and making us sort of
pseudo intimate,
a lot of us are really alone.
And that was a real,
that was a real eyeopener.
Uh,
excuse the Pun.
I think this is a really profound point that you're making and the pseudo
intimacy I think is a great way to put it.
I,
I I tend to unexpectedly at times brush just enter a zone of sort of profound
loneliness and it's the,
the irony in some ways I think is that of course you have,
you have an incredibly loyal fan base.
And uh,
I've,
I'm very fortunate to have a really fantastic group of readers and listeners and
I'm,
I find it so easy to love them,
to love my friends,
to love my family.
If I had a very difficult sometimes to love myself,
it seems almost self indulgent and that's kind of weird.
You could,
I'm sure there's plenty of analysis that can be done on that.
But one of the most therapeutic,
we were talking about,
you mentioned yoga before we got started and also again here,
one of the most therapeutic unexpectedly therapeutic experiences I've had in the
last six months is starting to play with something called Acro Yoga where you
are
yeah,
Yoga and you,
there's a trust element and a vulnerability element of balancing each other
upside down and staring.
You have to maintain at points I contact and it's,
it's a very visceral,
primal need that is being satisfied.
Um,
anyway,
I,
I don't want to ramble on,
but it's,
it's been a really profound realization for me that I can't think myself out of,
I can't think myself out of this loneliness.
No.
Yeah.
I mean we,
I think we think that we can think a lot of things.
You know,
we can think our way out of a relationship problem.
We can think our way out of a sexual problem and we can think our way out of a
work problem.
And to me,
Yoga and also like meditation and really trying to have,
um,
you know,
a constant level of body awareness.
It's so important because you really can get lost in your head.
And if you,
you know,
if you,
if,
if you demand that your head and your body are disconnected and you really can
just like,
as long as you sort of like feed your body and drag it around as a,
as a container for your mind,
everything's fine.
The,
the whole system starts to fall apart.
And I see that more and more,
especially as I get older.
Um,
if I neglect my body and I neglect like,
you know,
actual physical contact with other people for too long because it's just a pain
in the ass cause I just don't have time because I'm too busy this week to get to
yoga because it did,
it did.
It really like the,
the,
you know,
the whole building starts to feel like it's,
it's built on sound shit just falls down and,
you know,
I,
there's still something in us and in me because you know,
we are taught to be so rational and so had oriented the kind of don't want to
believe that it's true and the he can get away with it.
Um,
but you count it all eventually comes back to roost.
You mentioned meditation.
I'd love to dig into that for a second.
Uh,
and uh,
as I,
as I understand it,
you've also written about meditation before.
Um,
there's one piece that when I was doing better research,
melody versus meditation,
what,
what is your meditation practice look like?
And,
uh,
what,
what are the benefits that you've seen?
Well,
I have this special room in my house that's covered with candles and lots of
statues and I burned six sticks of incense and I drink a special stick tea and
then I float into the air and it's really rad.
Uh,
that's all,
that's all bullshit.
What I usually do,
uh,
if I'm,
if I'm being good is,
um,
first thing in the morning,
I will just use my phone as a timer and I will sit on whatever I can grab.
If I don't have a meditation cushion around,
I'll grab it up,
you know,
a bed pillow or a towel.
And I will sit cross legged somewhere.
If I'm,
you know,
a five minute teeny hotel or a friend's house,
sometimes it's in the bathroom or on the bed.
Um,
and I try to,
I tried to meditate for,
you know,
10 minutes if it's a crazy busy day and a half an hour,
if it's,
if I can carve out the time.
Um,
and I definitely notice,
I notice a huge difference in my day if I'm,
if I actually make the time to do that.
And you know,
I was,
um,
I was brought into the world of meditation in my,
you know,
my late teens,
early twenties,
and just basic vipassana meditation.
Nothing fancy,
no crazy mantras,
no,
no God's or deities just basically sitting,
sitting on the earth as a human being and paying attention to your breath.
And your body and letting thoughts come and go,
but really trying not to be attached to,
to the,
the drama that comes visiting.
And,
um,
I wish I could tell you I was great at it.
I've been meditating for 20 years and I still feel like a shitty meditator,
which I think,
I think that's,
I think that's part of the journey is realizing that it's,
you know,
it's not like you meditate for a year and all of a sudden you're,
you're enlightened and you can sit and think about nothing for a half an hour.
But what,
what you do learn is that,
um,
just the act of watching where your brain is obsessing for a half an hour,
you know,
and if my timer goes off after a half an hour of meditating and I realized that
all I have been doing is,
you know,
constructing an argument in my head with a person in my life or,
thinking about merge designs and I somehow lost the plot,
you know,
two minutes into my meditation and flew off.
Um,
that just tells me,
that tells me where my head is that it tells me that I'm stressed out.
It tells me that that's,
you know,
that's what's preoccupying me.
And on a good day,
um,
you know,
I think about constructing an argument,
I think about my list of things to do.
I think about what I'm about to eat when I get up and those thoughts come,
but I'm able to let them go five or 10 seconds later and say like,
hi,
okay,
I see you.
Yep,
you're here.
Okay,
now you're gone.
Let's,
you know,
let's go back to paying attention to our breath.
And then five seconds later it's another thought and you say hello to it and you
say goodbye to it.
And that's,
you know,
to me that's a much more,
quote unquote productive meditation practice.
But the real productive meditation practice is just that you sit your ass down
and you actually do it and you watch what happens.
That is the practice.
It's,
you know,
and it's never,
it's never easy,
but you do it.
You do get a perspective onto the inside of your head.
And your thought process that I think is essential if you're going to progress
because you get to know yourself,
you get,
you get to watch the little tricks that your brain is playing and you know,
and the places where you are obsessive and getting stuck.
And you know,
it has been in moments of meditation and honestly actually more moments in yoga.
I'm often just like at the end of a yoga class,
lying on a mat on the floor,
watching,
watching my thoughts enough that I'm not just caught and them where I have had
the most uh,
insightful,
um,
you know,
in,
I want to say the most insightful insights,
but you know,
I've had the most insightful moments of my life looking at my thoughts and
going,
are you serious Amanda?
Like you actually really just spent five minutes coming up with a plan that
actually you know,
is really destructive and yet your brain was having a field day with it.
And just,
and just the act of being able to stand back and saying,
wow,
you,
you're thinking this,
you've actually been thinking this way all your life.
This is not,
not necessarily good.
Maybe we should,
maybe we should find another way out of this problem or whatever.
And you know,
you,
you don't get insights like that unless you give yourself some perspective
because if you're just spending your life going and going and going and being
trapped in the thoughts and not giving yourself,
you know,
a different point of view,
you just,
you stay in the crazy.
Yeah.
I think the developing the skill is the observer is I found just so critical to
be able to step out of the rapids onto the shore and just observe it for a while
as opposed to being sort of trapped like a,
like a monkey in the,
in the slip stream of thought,
getting washed over the rocks.
And I've,
I mean as,
as you put it,
I think a lot of people have this past fail mentality with meditation where if
they can't think of a candle flame for 20 minutes straight,
they're a failure and they quit.
And then I tell people all the time,
I said,
look,
almost without fail,
every time I sit down to meditate,
a portion of it will be spent fantasizing about some elaborate retribution
against someone who like cut me in the salad line and college or something.
So fucking ridiculous.
Uh,
but it's the,
just the act of meditating somewhat like stretching,
I suppose it just gives you a certain responsiveness as opposed to reflexive
kneejerk response to stuff that I find very,
very helpful.
Yeah.
Well it is,
it is not unrelated to the,
um,
to the say last conversation we were having.
The ability to realize when you are not saying less,
uh,
is,
you know,
is directly related to the amount of perspective you can take in any given
moment argument,
you know,
conflict.
Definitely.
I would love to ask you a couple of questions that are a bit of a lateral step,
but I'm curious nonetheless.
Uh,
the first is what,
what book or books do you give most often or have you given most often as gifts
to other people?
Uh,
well,
um,
besides your own,
I suppose
that one doesn't count.
I go through phases,
but I have some,
I have some perennials.
Um,
and yeah,
to the,
that I can think of off the top of my head.
One is one is directly related to what we were just talking about.
Um,
mindfulness and,
and meditation and sort of the cutting through the bullshit.
One of my absolute favorite books of all time,
um,
because it changed my life is a,
is a book called dropping ashes on the Buddha.
It's by a zen master songs on,
and I read it who was a Korean zen monk and I read it when I was maybe 24 and
it's a short book and it's actually,
um,
it's just,
it's just a series of letters that this,
um,
really funny,
uh,
very direct,
very no bullshit Korean monk wrote back and forth with his students in the 70s.
And most of the students are Americans.
They're,
you know,
there are sort of that first wave of we are getting into meditation,
we are lost.
Please help guide us,
you know,
and the way this guy's ability to economically get to the point of what's
important and how to explain to somebody else how to cut through the bullshit
and just get to mindfulness was,
uh,
a game changer for me at 24 and all of the,
you know,
Yoga and meditation I had kind of dabbled with up until then sort of coalesced
and I,
and,
and that book really opened my mind.
Um,
it was sort of one of those,
Oh my God,
I think I get it.
Books.
And so I have,
I have given that book to probably 30 people or 40 people,
especially people who have told me that they are feeling kind of lost,
um,
and or depressed or directionless or at a,
you know,
younger people who are at crazy crossroads in their life and need something to
hang onto.
I've given many copies of that book
to read it.
It's,
it's fantastic.
Um,
and there's actually,
if you like it,
there is a companion book that was his second collection of letters called only
don't know which was wanting to just cause he's spoken this thick Korean accent
and had all these little hilarious ways of phrasing things,
which is one of the most amusing things about the book.
Um,
and he's,
he keeps saying to his students all of the time,
only say,
oh,
you don't know.
It was just,
you know,
just great create accent.
So my other one that I have given to a gazillion people,
which is sort of on the flip side of the other,
like metaphysical side of the fence is a bill Bryson,
who's one of my favorite nonfiction writers,
wrote a book called a short history of nearly everything,
which is,
I don't know if you've read Bill Bryson,
but you know,
he's one of the,
he's one of those guys.
Like he could write about anything and I would read it.
Yeah.
What does it going to the wilderness or he has one about hiking the,
or attempting to hike the Appalachian trail
that,
that I,
I,
I love that.
I've read all of his stuff.
And He,
so he decides to,
you know,
as an every man with a basic understanding of,
uh,
the history of the earth and,
you know,
basically,
the,
the history of science and how things work,
decides to tackle this with his basic knowledge and,
you know,
spends a few years researching a book and just the first 20 or 30 pages of this
book are of Great Comfort to me.
It gives these,
he spends pages expounding on exactly how small the earth is
in relation to the rest of the universe.
And,
you know,
along with,
uh,
like reading about zen meditation or anything,
if anything is going to put you in a good mood or maybe send you into an
existential angst,
full crisis,
knowing how totally insignificant your life as a human being on the planet earth
is in the grand scheme of things.
And we're talking space and time.
This book is just like,
it just,
you know,
is incredibly humorous,
but also is just one of those great perspectives where you read it and you,
you,
you feel totally emotionally connected to bill Bryson.
And,
uh,
and his desire and his hunger to learn these things.
And also,
um,
you know,
it,
you get to feel like an,
you know,
your,
your place in the,
your insignificance in the cosmos and it's,
that's a,
that's another favorite and the,
and that's just in the nonfiction department.
Fiction I think is for another podcast.
We can do that in around two for sure.
Uh,
well I know,
I know what I'm getting on my kindle then.
Those,
uh,
particularly dropping ashes on the Buddha,
I thought I had the collection of letters.
Format is really one of my favorites,
so I'm excited to,
to grab that.
Uh,
so this,
uh,
a lot of what we've talked about ties into directly or indirectly how people
define success.
And I'd be curious to know,
when you hear the word successful,
who's the first person you think of and why?
Oh,
God.
Um,
you know,
it's funny when you said it,
the first person who popped into my head was Neal,
but that's probably because I just spent all day with him and he is successful.
Uh,
you know,
the only,
I,
it may feel
like a dodge to answer it this way,
but,
um,
success is something that has been so plastic,
uh,
and,
and fungible in my life,
especially because I live in a,
you know,
I live in a world in entertainment and in performance and you know,
now and book writing,
it's,
it is a,
it is a competitive field.
It's not like,
you know,
my,
my sister or you know,
someone else who just has a job in science and you know,
it gets their job at the university and maybe I'm,
maybe I'm full of shit and everybody out there with any job from shoemaking to
plumbing feels highly competitive.
But you know,
especially being a female singer,
the world sort of views you as being in competition with the woman next to you.
You know,
right down to the fact that you are on the charts here and she is on the charts
there and the world measures you and measures your success by a number of
downloads,
number of fans,
number of Twitter followers or whatever.
And I have found that part of the struggle of actually finding happiness as an
artist is the,
is the daily fight to not define success.
By the way the rest of the world defines success,
which is hard because you,
you have to fight the same battles every day because you go out into the,
into the work environment and the entire industry and even,
you know,
to a certain extent your own fans because they're sort of all drinking the same.
Kool aid are,
are our kind of all telling you,
well success is defined by this success as defined by the success as defined by
this and you're there in your own little bubble going,
well I know that's not really true.
I know that,
you know,
there is that superficial level of success.
But then there's also my personal success,
which no one else can define for me.
And a really is only defined by how happy was I when I woke up this morning and
how happy am I when I'm betting down at night.
And that's not reflected in any of the billboard charts or in any of the iTunes
download iTunes downloads.
So,
you know,
success has this bizarro two faced.
Um,
w w you know,
uh,
I'm losing my words today.
Um,
what's the word for what a thing is
perfect.
So yeah,
success has this very two faced essence where,
um,
you know,
you,
you especially as a artist playing the game in the industry and putting out
music and putting out books and so forth,
you kind of have to play that game a little bit and ride the balance of um,
you know,
trying to get your book on The New York Times best selling list and knowing what
to do to do that.
Uh,
but also simultaneously not drinking the Koolaid,
like swishing it around in your mouth and then spitting it out,
going for a success tasting.
Exactly.
It's like being a wine Somalia who doesn't drink.
Um,
and you know,
I think I,
speaking of,
you know,
of meditation at all kind of
this,
this wines together and is it,
is it actually a really good example of the sort of thing I would notice myself
thinking and,
and,
and finally get to a point where I could really catch myself in the act of
comparing myself to other artists and being jealous of people who had more
charts success or being jealous of artists who seemed to me to be more
successful and so in my crazy brain and they must somehow be happier or must
somehow have beat me or must somehow have something that I don't have.
And it's honestly,
it's in the moments of Yoga and meditation that I find myself,
it's like you and your revenge plot against the person who cut you in the salad
bar.
My moments like that are going,
oh my God,
I really am doing that thing.
I really am thinking about,
you know,
Fiona Apple,
Regina Spektor or you know,
Lady Gaga as the person who has sold more records and therefore must be happier.
Why didn't I make that decision?
Why am I not where they have?
Why did I not do this?
Why didn't I go into fashion?
Why didn't,
and,
and watching an actually having the ability to watch my brain and stand back and
go,
you know,
Amanda,
you realize that that's not actually success.
You realize that even if you had that,
you know,
whatever thing,
axes,
it's not going to buy you happiness.
Just sit with that for a second and notice what you're doing.
And,
and to that,
I am grateful,
really grateful for a mindfulness practice because I don't stop having those
crazy thoughts.
They come,
but I at least I can at least catch myself in the act and see that I'm doing it.
You're getting better at training them in the wild
in a way.
Perhaps the,
so this,
this is,
I think underscores a really important point.
I mean the,
the definition of success and the misconceptions or self delusion of that we can
get caught up in,
uh,
looking externally.
What are common misconceptions about you?
Ooh,
those people do think I know who Amanda Palmer is.
What are the common misconceptions?
I know who Amanda Palmer is.
He's that narcissistic talentless Harry Connick married to my favorite Neil
Gaiman.
Fuck her.
Um,
you know,
I would like to think in my darkest moments,
I,
I would like to think that the most common misconception about me is that I is
that I am not self reflective and that I,
and that I don't have self knowledge and that if I am a,
you know,
narcissistic,
evil attention getting,
um,
you know,
fill in the blank,
um,
that I am,
that I'm not the kind of person who knows myself and,
um,
and,
and dissects myself.
And one of,
you know,
one of the weird things about,
especially being a female performer is you,
you get a lot of the same grief.
You know,
you start to notice the patterns.
And you know,
when I was,
when I was in my mid twenties,
and it was sort of the dawn of the Dresden dolls and I sort of faced my first
wave of internet criticism,
and the main criticism was,
you know,
she's an attention whore.
That was the big,
that was sort of the big Goto for people.
And the amount of sort of like bravado,
you know,
and simultaneous shame that I felt when I would see people saying that about me.
It was really interesting because on the one hand,
you know,
it was intellectually and emotionally smart enough to go,
okay well people are calling me an attention whore,
but you know,
I'm a performing singer,
songwriter.
It,
my job is to get it running.
So I can see,
I can see the double standard here and I can also see that nobody is calling the
male artists who I opened up for or who opened up for me.
No one's calling him an attention whore.
I think this is a thing that's more or less aimed at me because I'm a woman.
But I could be wrong.
I mean,
you know,
maybe,
maybe this,
you know,
maybe there's something in this and maybe my,
maybe my very insecure secret self is right.
Maybe I am in this for all the wrong reasons.
Maybe I am just too narcissistic.
Maybe I am too hungry for attention.
Maybe I'm doing something wrong.
Um,
but honestly,
you know,
having no been in the business for,
it's now whatever it is,
13 years later since,
you know,
since I started the Dresden dolls,
I feel like I've seen enough waves of criticism and also detected enough
patterns after an off time and done enough self inquiry that I can,
I can sort of piece the puzzle together and get Yup.
I was kind of,
you know,
it was kind of right and I was kind of wrong.
Um,
mostly,
you know,
looking back at how I reacted in anger and fear at 25 I was mostly right.
Most of the people criticizing me,
you know,
as I was 25 and struggling to make it as a musician in Boston and you know,
aggressively pounding at the piano and aggressively,
you know,
wearing few clothes and aggressively doing whatever the fuck I wanted and
aggressively not caring about,
you know,
the etiquette and the fashions of the day.
Yeah.
Mostly people were threatened or angry,
but it didn't have a whole lot to do with me.
It mostly had to do with them.
And it still feels true.
And it's,
you know,
I think one of the,
I think one of the things you come to terms with as a performer and as a
specialty as a female performer is,
you know,
you are so desperate,
especially at the beginning of your career,
you are,
you are so desperate for universal approval,
universal love,
you know,
and you figure that if you do your job right and you really work hard and you
write fantastic songs and you are a consummate entertainer that everyone must
love you.
And it's not a bad way to be.
You aim high,
you aim for the center of the target and the like and the,
and the brass ring that's furthest away.
But also,
you know,
you realize whoever you are,
there is no universally beloved performer.
There are people out there who hate John Lennon there,
you know,
there's people out there who,
name an artist and there's people who hate them.
And one of the things that you,
um,
that you discover as you journeyed down your,
you know,
your livelihood,
um,
as a performer and you,
you sort of negotiate your own career is,
is sort of developing an acceptance that your audience is going to be your
audience and your audiences and everybody.
And there will be those out there,
you know,
who decide that you're not their cup of tea and the ear style rubs them the
wrong way and that they don't like your voice or they don't like your songs are,
they don't like your appearance or they just don't like you.
Um,
and it's just part,
part and parcel of the job.
And I remember people telling me it,
you know,
at 25 and at 27 and at 29,
that if I was being criticized,
if I was being criticized,
it was a,
it was a real sign of success.
And even though I intellectually knew that that took me years to actually
emotionally take on and feel the truth of that,
that if people are angered by you,
if people care enough to write about how they don't like hear music or write
about at this point,
you know,
write about how they don't like your book,
um,
you're doing something right because you know,
if you're being discussed at all and your work is of enough merit to merit
criticism,
then you're just on the path and you know,
you're not so naive,
you know,
as,
as you were at 24 thinking that if you just pushed all the right buttons,
everyone would eventually see the light and love you.
It doesn't work that way.
I think that you could mention any artist,
any person of note or who's had a decent amount of public exposure and they
probably have a hate page dedicated to them.
I mean,
it really doesn't matter who it is,
but you know,
you mentioned,
uh,
fans and wanting everyone to like what you do.
But certainly,
I mean,
I think that to business as an art,
if everyone is your customer,
the no one is your customer on some level,
you have your,
I think somewhat a famous for having a very die hard fan base.
And maybe this is a tired question,
but I would love to still hear from you why you think that's the case.
Um,
and I'll just,
I'll just leave it at that.
We can certainly dig into it,
but you have such a dedicated fan base,
I mean above and beyond in a way that has sort of mesmerized,
uh,
a lot of people in the music industry and elsewhere.
The ranging from the huge success of your Kickstarter campaign to the,
I think challenging the status quo,
which may be part of the reason that you get a lot of the flack that you do.
Um,
couch surfing with fans,
bringing fans up on stage.
There's so much we could dig into.
But why do you think your fans,
you have such a large contingent of die hard fans?
Well,
I,
I think that has to do with,
um,
you know,
how,
how specifically intimate my writing is.
Um,
because it's certainly not for everybody.
And you know,
I,
when I look back at my career,
you can hear me right?
Oh,
I can hear you.
Okay.
I just thought I lost myself for a second.
So when I look back at the last right,
10,
15 years of my life,
I definitely see a lot of moments where I could have turned to the left or it
could have turned
to the right and I could have made things like,
for lack of a better word,
more palatable,
more radio friendly,
more universal,
um,
more.
This is the kind of thing that I know more people can digest.
And when I look at those choices,
I pretty much have on,
on the whole chosen not to take that turn.
And which isn't to say that,
um,
I want to alienate people.
In fact,
the opposite is true,
but I,
I've kind of deliberately resisted commercial success mostly because as I grew
in my career,
which did grow slowly,
you know,
it's not like I started writing songs one day and then the Dresden dolls started
and then six months later we were famous.
I was on a really,
um,
you know,
really slow climb from the time I started as a songwriter,
as a teenager,
um,
to solo performing to meeting Brian and starting the band to touring locally for
three years to ultimately getting signed,
said a lot of time to sort of look around and gage,
um,
who I was and which bands I really admired and,
and kind of what forms of success were available to me.
Because,
you know,
when I was 18,
there was only one thing.
It was like,
get on MTV,
be famous.
That was success.
Um,
but then as you know,
as I grew into my twenties,
I realized there were a lot of,
a lot of artistic choices on a lot of lifestyle choices open to me,
and I was master of my own fate.
I was allowed to choose whether I was going to be the kind of artist who spent
two hours getting ready before shows,
doing massive hairdos,
putting on makeup,
getting into fashion,
trying to work with pop producers,
you know,
putting dancing in my videos,
really trying to sell myself as someone who could hopefully ultimately go
platinum and sell 4 million records.
And I,
you know,
part part of the curse is if you,
if you want to look at it that way,
um,
which I don't,
but it was like I learned too much too soon and I knew that going the lady Gaga
route or whatever and taking,
taking the,
you know,
the bear structure of my songs and handing them over to a pop producer to turn
them into dance hits wasn't necessarily going to make me a happier person.
I just sensed it.
I'm an,
I don't want this to come across sounding pretentious or anything because I
think there's really different ways of being happy.
And I think it's very possible that lady Gaga is happy.
And I don't know because I don't know her,
but I,
I looked at,
you know,
my life is a long expanse of time,
energy choices and who I was going to get to hang out with.
And I was like,
you know,
I think it may mean less chart success,
radio success,
less chances of getting on an MTV.
But I know if I make this choice and this choice and not choice,
it's more probable that I'm going to enjoy my day.
And so those are the choices I kept making.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Is that what you mean by lifestyle choices?
Is it a quality of life thing or is it something else?
Well,
I mean one,
it's both,
you know,
the choice too.
And you know,
there's just some certain things,
especially if you're talking about pop life,
you know,
there's certain choices as a woman where like some shit just comes down to time
and energy.
I got into a conversation about this on Facebook.
I have never spent any time doing my hair.
And it may seem,
it may seem stupid or you know,
like a kind of irrelevant thing,
but I actually know,
you know,
for the pop stars out there who kind of want to do the Fashionista thing and um,
take that particular fork.
It's,
it just takes time out of your day if you want to,
you know,
if you want to go in that direction and do fashion and,
always look photo ready and vogue ready on stage.
I know what it takes.
I've done it for video shoots,
I've done it for photo shoots.
You need to sit in a chair for two hours.
And I sort of looked at that and was like,
ah,
I don't want to sit in a chair for two hours.
I want to spend that two hours going out to dinner with my friends in
Philadelphia and hearing about their art projects and I want to spend that two
hours,
you know,
needing ingredient with fans before the show.
So I get that it's kind of a sacrifice and I get that.
I won't look like Katy Perry on stage,
but it's okay,
I'll give that up.
I'll make this choice and not that choice.
So I've,
I've been fascinated with your story on so many levels and one of them,
if,
if you're able to discuss it
relates to crossroads that I find myself in,
which is being tired of the,
the charts,
the New York Times bestseller list,
I'm just fatigued by it.
I've been through that game several times.
It's exhausting.
It's not objective.
It's really a,
there is a,
a very subjective kind of editor's choice element to it that I dislike because I
don't feel it's,
I feel,
uh,
that it's,
it's not,
uh,
it's not a real reflection of the true success of any given book.
And I was hoping maybe we could chat about the,
uh,
the rebellion and,
splitting with roadrunner records if you're able to talk about that,
because I was,
if you could give people a little bit of context on that.
Um,
I,
you know,
I'm thinking of going completely indeed as a writer potentially,
uh,
moving forward and there's a certain appeal and the simplicity of that.
And we'll see if I have the fortitude to do it.
But are you able to give people a little bit of context on what happened with
roadrunner and then what you learned from that?
Sure.
Um,
well the,
the rebellion specifically,
or is this a,
this hilarious moment in my career,
this would have been 2008,
um,
I had put out my first solo record who killed Amanda Palmer.
I was really proud of it.
I still am,
I think it's a great record.
And there was a song on it called Leeds United,
um,
that was like a big band,
crazy drunk and brash,
you know,
uh,
it was one of sort of one of the populist songs on the record and I decided to
make a video for it.
I made the video in London.
It was really fun.
Um,
and the,
the record label at the time,
I was still on road runner records.
I had things with them adjust or to start falling apart because they,
they barely lifted a finger to promote the dress and all his second album.
And um,
that left us feeling really disillusioned.
But I sort of gave them a chance to,
you know,
to make good,
um,
on,
on my,
my first solo record,
which came out right after that.
And uh,
they didn't,
by the way,
long story short,
but,
um,
somewhere in there there's video got shot and the rough cut was sent over to the
label and I in,
in the,
at the time in between had made my way back to New York and the NR guy called me
into his office
advertising and something else.
Uh,
technically it in old school terms that meant artists and repertoire.
but in,
in,
in Layman's terms,
your,
your ANR guy is basically your,
your representative,
your dude.
Cause it's usually a dude,
but you know,
your dude or Gal at the label who is,
you know,
the artist liaison base point of contact.
Got It.
Yeah.
Your,
your person.
So my person,
Dave,
um,
Dave wrath,
bless heart,
because he had to do,
he had,
he had to speak for the trees
and he called me into his office and tried as delicately as he could to tell me
that the label had had a meeting and they thought that I loved too fat and the
video and would I be willing to cut the shots that showed my bare midriff.
And I was astounded at this because I am vain and I had seen the rough cut and I
thought I looked fantastic.
I was really thrilled that,
you know,
I had been a little,
cause you know I'm not,
I'm not trim,
but I'm,
you know,
I have like I have my little pot belly,
but you know,
some pot belly that can be,
can be attractive as long as it's not hanging out over your pants.
And I was actually really thrilled when I saw the rough cut because I thought I
looked fantastic.
And so I sat there with my jaw dropped to the floor going like,
you're getting me?
No.
Like what shots are you talking about?
Cause I think I look great and I'm a vain motherfuckers.
So like you just clearly disagree.
And,
and I,
at that point I had kind of had it with the label and I had sort of decided at
that point to just probably split off and go my own way.
So I basically did,
I did an act of war and I posted to my blog,
I posted the story to my blog knowing that my fans would all be aggrieved and
everyone would,
you know,
would be sad on my behalf.
Uh,
and at the end of the day,
the,
the label back down,
they,
you know,
they put the video out.
They of course did nothing to promote it,
which know it was probably shooting myself in the foot.
But who knows.
Um,
and this was also at the point where this,
you know,
the video was basically Internet only.
So it was up to me to do any promoting that was going to happen.
And
this beautiful organic internet moment happened where I shared this story and
that was it.
I gave no directive.
And then on their own,
the fans created this movement where they started a page on the band forum
uploading selfies of their own stomachs with messages written on them to road
runner,
her saying things like this is what a normal belly looks like and you know,
fuck the label and long live.
And they gave the movement a title,
which was the rebelly and get it cause their belly was in the middle.
Um,
but this wasn't just a couple of people or even a couple of dozen people.
This is like hundreds of fans did this.
And it was hilarious because it was a lot of,
you know,
huge man bellies and teeny little baby bellies and people,
wrote on their cats and stuff.
It was fucking hilarious.
And someone,
even a one of the fans even like collected all of these photos and po published
a little chat book and you know,
with my permission like,
which they didn't even need,
you know,
printed up a thousand of these books and just offered to send them to be
pleasant.
And it was just,
it was one of those moments where I stood back like a proud parent.
I looked at my fan base and I was like,
you guys are awesome.
I just love that you fucking did this.
You're creative and you're weird and you're,
and you're all with me.
And that was just,
it was also one of those moments where I looked at them
and this was,
this is my demographic.
Like these were my fans,
these are the people for whom the video was made and they were all so,
you know,
they were all so proud of me and also so happy for me to be authentic.
And I,
I sort of looked over at the label who were like,
Whoa,
you know,
Amanda,
if you really want to be successful,
you have to Xyz.
And I was like,
you know,
I really don't think you guys get it.
This is my audience.
This is who I'm making the video for.
This is who I'm thinking for the music for.
They understand,
you guys don't seem to,
I think this relationship has come to that.
And,
um,
but it was also,
it was,
you know,
as you look back at Internet history,
it was one of those moments where,
you know,
in 1995 that wouldn't have happened.
But these people all found each other groups together and could create their own
moment.
And it's one of the blessings of the Internet,
which is,
you know,
the paradigm shifts the people in power.
Um,
you know,
really everything is called into question and it's very possible that a 1995 I
might have believed the label.
I might not have understood that,
you know,
that my audience really did just want me the authentic take me not the
airbrushed one.
And you know,
and this is why it's sort of been a,
it's been a lifelong conversation,
a dialogue with my fan base.
It's not just me,
the artist with the megaphone.
If you had to choose one way online to communicate with your audience,
what would you choose?
As it stands right now,
if I only got to use one social media platform or do I have to choose between
Twitter and email?
Yeah,
you have to choose.
So it'd be one online tool,
whether it's social network or otherwise.
What would you choose and why?
Ah,
if I could only communicate one way on the Internet,
you know,
probably Twitter because Twitter has direct messaging so I could email people.
That's true.
You could,
you could
well,
email,
uh,
email camps,
um,
you know,
for lack of a better word,
email can't,
uh,
it's only person to person so it can't collect,
you know,
you can't create a movement on email or,
unless if that were the case,
I would probably find myself,
you know,
kind of on,
on massive chain group emails with 900 people all be cc'd into conversation.
Uh,
let me ask a couple of fun questions,
couple of listeners who were very curious to know,
how do you,
what is the dynamic like having two creatives in,
in one household.
So your,
your husband is,
is of course,
a very
prolific writer.
You have many different creative endeavors.
Uh,
what is the,
do you,
would you work together?
Do you work separately?
Do you ask each other advice?
Is there collaboration?
Do you,
how do your creative tempos differ?
That's a lot at once,
so you can kind of answer it however you want.
But I'm just so fascinated to know how that,
how you guys make that work.
Oh boy.
That's a huge question.
I mean,
it's a huge lot of questions.
I think the biggest blanket answer is we help each other a lot.
Um,
but we also have private areas and rooms where we really don't fuck with each
other.
Um,
and we've,
we've learned the hard way,
you know,
I have learned,
um,
and if,
you know,
if anything,
if any,
if nothing else,
Neil and I have have found that we are insanely similar.
Um,
and we,
and we both constantly make the mistake of thinking that the other one has a
thicker skin than they do when the truth is we are both at our core,
really fragile artists.
Um,
and,
and I think most artists at their core are,
you know,
may seem the thick skinned,
but when it comes down to it,
you know,
we really want people to love and understand our work.
And so I've learned,
you know,
I've been with Neil for six years and I still am constantly fine tuning how
honest to be with him about something he shows me and vice versa.
You know,
Neal,
Neal resumes something.
He wrote a couple,
you know,
a couple of weeks ago and I gave,
I gave him my honest opinion and I immediately wanted to take it back cause I
was like,
you should have just not use God amount of why to give say that now he's going
to be depressed for three days.
And he was um,
cause like,
you know,
I didn't particularly love this or that and was totally blunt and you know,
and I would have,
I would've wanted the same thing from him if I had,
you know,
if I had written a piece of music and played it for him and no one had heard it
yet.
And I was feeling my small,
fragile self crawling out of my little art cave,
waving my watercolor around as
even when you're 54 I totally think of,
you know,
that whether it's a novel or a song or a poem or an opera or whatever it is.
To me,
you're still five showing your mom a watercolor going.
Do you like it?
I'm,
the only answer is yes,
you're a genius.
I am putting that on the fridge.
That's your water color.
I don't know what it is.
It's totally abstract.
I know it's supposed to be a tree and it doesn't really look like a tree,
but every,
every artist in that way is kind of five.
And you and you really do have to choose your words carefully.
And you know,
on the other hand,
the reason Neil and I love each other and respect each other so much,
it's we don't really bullshit each other,
you know?
And we know,
we speak the language,
we know that there's a difference between holy fuck.
I think that's the best thing you've ever written.
And yeah,
that's,
that's really good.
Yeah.
You know,
and those are basically two ends of the spectrum.
And you're,
you really,
you know,
if you're trying to be kind and a good attentive arts vous,
you're really not supposed to go into,
you know,
just,
uh,
I think I get it.
Not your best work.
I didn't really dig it.
Like you're just not allowed to say that.
So we're like a Japanese tea ceremony,
you know,
and that's what the work itself,
we also help each other with,
you know,
more of the nerdy stuff.
We edit each other on social media.
There have been nights where one of us has,
and this has happened in both directions,
where one will text the other and be like,
for fuck's sake,
delete that.
Or you find yourself in the middle of an Internet shitstorm tomorrow because you
have pressed tomorrow and you're too busy to spend all day writing a blog
defending your right to Xyz.
And,
and 90% of the time the person will be like,
you know,
I knew you.
I knew not to do it.
I just want to know,
fuck it.
You're right.
I'll delete it.
Um,
distinctly non-Americans I'm guessing you get a fair number of those.
We both,
we both do that for each other and we,
you know,
we not only text each other and say,
hey,
delete that tweet.
You're an idiot.
Um,
but we'll also,
we'll run,
we'll run things by each other.
You know,
Neil and I have both stepped in the middle of controversies unwittingly.
Neil more recently than me,
he had got himself in an Internet shit storm with the title of his most recent
book and we,
you know,
we sat in bed and had long conversations about is this a really a good idea.
And you know,
when people come yelling at you,
how are you going to deal?
And you know,
why don't you actually write something in the introduction of the book to
explain it so that you can kind of proactively blah blah blah.
Like we sit there like a couple of marketing managers
dealing with the kerfuffle before it actually blows in the window.
But we both,
we've both been there and we've both been there holding the hand of the other
while the other stands in the Internet.
Shit storm,
you know,
having to deal with the op eds and the angry tweets and the angry tumbler
people.
And there's something really wonderful about having a spouse who really
fundamentally understands you and has your back.
We,
we deeply understand each other and we,
we,
and we deeply share a philosophy about,
you know,
life work,
freedom of speech and compassion that even,
even if we express it differently is one of the reasons we were so attracted to
each other to begin with.
It was like,
Oh,
you're,
you're one of me.
I see.
I see what you're doing over there at,
got it.
And um,
and there,
there's something really,
there's something really comforting about that,
um,
because it's,
it can be a really lonely job when you're out there trying to explain,
you know,
how your work was misunderstood,
how your book title was misunderstood,
how your intention was misunderstood.
It's nice to,
you know,
deal with that kind of bullshit on the Internet all day and then sit down to
dinner with someone and have them deeply understand,
you know,
not just the intellectual bit of it,
but how it emotionally feels to go through a day like that.
Yeah.
Someone else has been deployed to the Internet before,
I think to catch that
last questions.
You walk into a bar,
what do you order from the bartender?
What temperature is it outside?
It is Boston in the winter.
Oh,
I ordered or red wine or a hot toddy.
Okay.
Oh,
hot toddy.
Good choice.
Uh,
if you could give one piece of advice to your 20 year old self,
what would it be?
Uh,
leave college.
Okay.
Leave transferable.
You're still a sophomore and go to art school in New York is what I've been
telling us.
Leave the liberal arts bubble for God's sake.
Ron,
will you still have time,
although you know,
in the,
uh,
back to the future timespace continuum problem.
Would I be talking to you right now about my wonderful marriage to Neil Gaiman
and my best selling book?
I don't know.
So dicey time travel.
It's dicey time travel.
I think,
you know,
I've got no regrets,
but I'm sure if I had,
um,
if I had a,
if I had escaped my shitty situation at 20,
I might have just jumped into another shitty situations.
Well,
this,
this has been so much fun.
I want to be respectful of your time.
Um,
press we can do around two sometime.
Oh,
I would love to,
I could talk for hours.
This is really fun.
Where can people find you on the internets and say hello and learn about what
you're up to.
And so,
ah,
people can find me in the obvious places.
You know,
you can Google up,
uh,
Amanda Palmer on pretty much any social media site.
Amanda Palmer on Twitter and I'm on Facebook and I actually,
one cool thing that you might not find googling is I just created a special page
of my website for people who aren't familiar with my music because I've had so
many people,
um,
coming to me as blog readers and readers of the book and as followers of me on
Twitter who,
who actually didn't come through the music that came through some other avenue
and really want to get to know the music but are kind of overwhelmed by,
you know,
the whole catalog.
And so I created a page on my automatic to palmer.net that's called a walk
through Amanda Landa
starts with the beginning of the Dresden dolls and kind of walks you through the
basic albums and what the singles on the albums were and what the best videos
are.
And it's,
it's a really good primer if you want to just go in and sample,
you know,
the last 13 years of,
of albums and music and stuff.
And it's pretty funny I wrote it.
So
I think if you Google amount of landing and they find it or just go to Amanda
Palmer dotnet and kind of have a browse around
and your name on Twitter is,
it's just at Amanda Palmer.
You got and you got the name.
That's a good one to have a awesome,
well Amanda,
thank you so much.
Uh,
everyone who's listening of course I'll put links to everything that I can track
down that we've talked about in the show notes,
the books,
Amanda,
Landa,
everything that was mentioned.
And I will let you get on to another creative day,
I'm sure.
So thank you so much for the time.
Yeah,
thank you Tim.
I think you are awesome.
And um,
if you decide to,
uh,
fly solo,
um,
Godspeed.
Thank you.
It's,
it,
it's,
it's a,
it's a lot of work,
but boy is it satisfying.
Got To jump off,
jump off and grow wings on the way down.
Yeah.
I mean one final thought on that,
cause I wanted to say something when you said that.
I think,
you know,
I went,
I went solo and did solo music,
everything once I dragged off the label.
But then I decided to put my book out with like,
you know,
one of one of the biggest publishers.
And you know,
I think the freedom to pick and choose is more important than the freedom of
being independent.
I think.
I think what,
and it really is,
it's like,
you know,
work with the men when you're digging the man and the man can actually help you
make your art and then don't wing it when you don't want to.
But you know,
there is no such thing as true freedom because you're always trading,
you know,
you're always trading something for something else.
And having tried to run my own record label and all of that,
you really do appreciate,
you know,
the people sitting in offices doing shuffling the papers that they do shuffle.
So you know when in doubt,
and if you go through round one,
two,
three and four,
just remember that you,
at the end of the day,
you get to do whatever the fuck you want.
Whether it's work with a publisher or work with yourself and you get to change
your mind 10 times if you want to.
Cause I have,
well I wish you and yours many more adventures and uh,
I hope we get a chance to have a hot toddy in person soon.
I would love that.
And we can invite Neil and he can talk in British at you.
Oh,
I would love that.
I want him to narrate my entire life,
uh,
with all of his free time.
Just like so soothing.
I want Neil Gaiman to narrow my entire
doesn't pay well.
Granted,
but uh,
but we could,
we could talk about that over alcohol.
No,
but you know,
you could create the APP
you don't have to do is get him to read the entire Oxford English dictionary.
That's it.
You could make gazillions on the Neil Gaiman narrate your life.
It's true.
All right.
Well Amanda,
uh,
you're very sweet and Virginia's for taking the time.
I really appreciate it and you're an inspiration.
Thank you.
You work too.
Take it easy.
Bye.
This episode of the Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is the world's largest online marketplace of graphic designers and I
have used 99 designs for years including to get cover concepts for the four hour
body which went on to become number one New York Times number one wall journal.
It was a huge hit and here's how it works and you can check everything out
including some of my competitions.
You can see these book covers and so on@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim
whether you need a logo,
a car wrap,
a web design and APP,
a thumbnail,
a tee shirt,
whatever.
You go to 99 designs.com you describe your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas and designs and drafts.
You have an original design that you love or you pay nothing.
It is fantastic.
I have used it.
I have mentioned it before,
including in the four hour work week as a resource.
Check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
And if you use that link,
you'll be able to see what I've done on the platform.
You will also get $99 as an upgrade for free,
which will get you more designs,
more submissions.
So check it out.
And until next time,
thank you for listening.
Yeah.